[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to another one
of our San Diego Google Talks.
We're really lucky to have Rick
Schwartz with us here today.
He is the global ambassador
for the San Diego Zoo.
He is here to talk to us
about the entire journey
that the Diego Zoo has had.
Almost--
RICK SCHWARTZ: Not
the entire journey.
That's a pretty big journey,
SPEAKER: I mean it's over
a century, so it's a lot.
And he'll talk to us little bit
about what their focus is today
and how far they've come along.
He has a couple of
videos to share.
And for those of you in the
audience who've already heard,
he also brought some furry
animals or non-furry animals--
RICK SCHWARTZ: Some
non-furry ones, too.
SPEAKER: --to come join us
with their zookeepers is
what you would call those?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah.
I've got keepers with us here.
SPEAKER: Their caretakers.
So we'll save questions
towards the end.
We have a couple of ones
we want to get through,
and Rick already has
a lot of content he
wants to share with you guys.
So we'll go ahead
and get started.
Well, welcome.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Well, thank you.
Thank you.
And hello, everyone in
the audience and hello
everyone that are
watching online as well.
It's sounds pretty
awesome to be here.
We've actually, for
the last two years,
had some opportunities to
talk to the Google campus up
in the Bay Area, as
well, do live programs up
there for their special events.
So it's kind of fun
to be here in our home
office in San Diego.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And we're fairly new.
So we're really taking that
theme of celebrating local San
Diego, and, of course, the
zoo is a big part of that.
So take us back
to the beginning.
1916, it all gets started.
You guys just had your
100-year anniversary.
RICK SCHWARTZ: We did.
We did.
SPEAKER: How did it all begin?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Well,
Let's see if I've
got the right button here.
Nope.
That says no.
Which button should
I push to make it go?
Oh, there's-- That one.
All right.
I let you do that then.
So on this slide
right here is kind
of a perfect view of Balboa
Park about 100 years ago.
And so the San Diego
Zoo started because
of the California-Panama
Exposition that occurred.
And if you're not
familiar with that,
essentially, long story short,
the Panama Canal opened up.
And about a year
before it opened,
San Diego was
roughly about 39,000,
40,000 people in population.
And all the ships would always
go past them to LA and up
to San Francisco as well.
So this was an
opportunity they want
to showcase on a global level,
or at least semi-global,
that they are a good stop,
as well, whether it's
for merchant or for visits.
And Balboa Park,
at the time, was
sort of this large swath of land
between San Diego proper, which
we call downtown San
Diego now, and some
of the smaller suburbs of North
Park and University Heights.
So with that, the idea
was to have this big event
to celebrate San Diego.
As that wrapped up,
then, and as vendors
pulled out-- some of them
didn't do so well financially.
They just cut their
losses and left--
a lot of things were
left in Balboa Park that
weren't expected
to be left there,
and that included some animals.
Imagine Balboa Park, looking
somewhat like that slide,
with some elk running
through it, some bears,
some coyotes, and
yes, even some lions.
And that's where we
get the whole idea
that it started with a roar.
Now, the majority of the
enclosures for the expo
were along, what we
call, Park Boulevard now.
And it was these long
rows of enclosures
where people could see animals.
And the whole thing really
started for the San Diego Zoo
when this gentleman here,
Dr. Harry Wegeforth, who
was a local surgeon,
he and his brother
were returning from doing
surgery at the local hospital,
and they heard
some lions roaring.
Now, what I know about lions
is they roar in the morning
hours and the evening hours.
So and since he just
finished surgery,
I assume it's the evening time.
And that's where the term "it
began with a roar" comes from.
Dr. Harry heard that roar,
turned to his brother, said,
you know, I've always
thought it would
be fun to have a zoo
here in San Diego.
I think I'll do it.
And his brother knew
him well enough,
because they grew up together.
Dr. Harry had a history of
always being out in the dirt
and looking for animals and
growing up near the woods
where he grew up, that his
brother wasn't too surprised.
That was September of 1916.
So now, October 2,
1916, it officially
became the Zoological
Society of San Diego.
Dr. Harry brought
his friends together.
They pitched to the
city to start the zoo.
And the city was, like,
nope, we don't want that.
So they came up with
the Zoological Society
of San Diego, which is a
nonprofit organization,
to run a zoo for the kids.
He reached out to the
schools in the area,
as well, along with
other philanthropists
to kind of get things going.
They gathered up some
of the animals that
were left in the zoo and
started their whole thing.
And from there,
it's always kind of
been this groundbreaking
zoological organization.
I've been with the organization
for about 17 years now,
and I can't believe all the
changes I've seen in my time.
I can't imagine how
forward-thinking Dr.
Harry must have been.
So the slide you
see here, right now,
you have some billy goats on
this old concrete platform.
It doesn't seem like much
to today's standards.
But keep in mind, this was
1930s when this photo was taken.
It used to be in
that time, animals
were in what we
originally saw right here.
This is what an animal enclosure
looks like at a zoo in America
at that time.
Dr. Harry wanted to try and
show the animals what they could
do-- or show people, I should
say, what the animals could do,
offering up exhibit spaces that
allowed mountain goats to climb
something that's
somewhat of a mountain
structure for the time.
And so the concept was always
forward-thinking for San Diego
Zoo even in its infancy.
And that really brings us up
to date to where we are now.
And what I'd like to do.
We'll stop here at the
very best care slide
and bring out one of our
animal friends for you guys
because I know you weren't just
here to see slides all day.
And this kind of ties
into what we talked about,
that forward-thinking concept.
We have a 21-year-old crested
porcupine coming out right now.
This is Pokey.
Appropriately named, right?
SPEAKER: [CHUCKLES] Pokey.
RICK SCHWARTZ: And she
is actually trained.
Now, how many of you knew
you could train a porcupine,
much less put one
on a leash, right?
The idea of what we do
for training purposes
and for care purposes,
we always try
to think what's best
for the animal, what's
best for their longevity, and
21 years old for a porcupine
is pretty darn old.
This particular species is
found in Africa and in India,
and so there's the African
and Indian crested porcupines.
They are a bit different
than our North American
species, of course.
But to give you some quick
fun facts, they are a rodent,
so that means their front
teeth are always growing,
the incisors are always growing.
And they can bring food to their
mouth with their front feet.
And if you want to walk
Pokey along, you can.
Let everyone see up close.
SPEAKER: How old is Pokey?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Pokey
is 21 years old.
So that's pretty
old for a porcupine.
If she sneezes, just
kind of block your face,
so the quills don't
go in your face.
I'm kidding.
That's a myth.
They can't actually
shoot their quills.
Quills are a modified hair.
They grow out of a root
follicle just like your hair.
And they're made of
the same proteins
as hair and fingernails.
That's what makes them
so firm and stiff.
So think of your fingernail
being kind of rolled up
into a straw.
And I say straw because they
are somewhat hollow inside.
In our North American
species, the quills
are smaller, more like
large toothpicks, where
in this species, of
course, much more
like a large stick or a pen.
Now, the longer
ones you see there
that act more like a skirt,
those are the more cover ones.
They would flare those
up and really show
the big sharp ones underneath
when they felt under attack.
You might also get a chance
to see the ones in the tail.
Looked like someone
trimmed them with scissors.
They grow naturally that way
because they're hollow inside.
That's one way they can
warn other large animals
like elephants or any other
large hoofed animal or even
predators.
They shake that tail real quick.
It makes a rattling, a very
staccato rattling noise.
It's the universal alarm
in the animal kingdom
to say, look out.
Don't step on me.
So what they could do
with their quills, though.
If you get cold, sometimes
you get goosebumps, right,
or something startles you?
That's an involuntary
action of muscles you have
that are attached to your
root follicles of your hair.
Porcupines, and
many other species,
have a voluntary muscle
control of those.
So if she were to be under
attack from her left side,
she could flare all her
quills off to that left side.
If you felt she was under
attack on her right side or even
from the front, she
could bow her head down
and bring those quills forward.
I have seen video footage
of two lionesses trying
to get one of these, and it
didn't work out very well
for the lionesses.
So it's a very effective form
of defense for the porcupine.
SPEAKER: So what is Pokey
eating, or what's his food?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Pokey gets a
mixture of different fruits
and vegetation.
Sweet potatoes on
the list right now.
And also usually get
a little bit of corn.
And we have what's called
[INAUDIBLE] biscuits.
So similar to what you would
have as a fortified dry food
for your dog or cat at home.
We do have those
that have formulated
in zoological settings
for zoo animals, as well,
and allows us to
make sure they get
sort of a baseline fortified
diet and the extra fruits
and vegetables and offer
up more nutrition for them.
SPEAKER: Nice.
So what's their ideal habitat.
Like, where do I find
all the porcupines.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Well,
this particular species,
their ideal habitats
more savanna,
dry forest areas, what
we call a scrub area.
Kind of similar what we might
actually have in this area,
but just over in Africa
and Asia, of course.
They would burrow and have
burrows they would be down in.
This species does not climb
like our North American
species does.
You might see the
behaviors we're asking for
and the reward comes.
You hear that clicking sound.
We use clickers when
training our animals.
For those of you who have
kids or were ever a kid,
you know that between
two parents and one child
there can be some
miscommunication sometimes
because someone says
something different.
Now, imagine one child
with seven parents.
A lot of our animals have
upwards of five, six,
or seven trainers depending upon
the schedule and the animal.
The clicker allows it
to stay consistent.
No matter who's working with
that animal, when they've
done the right behavior, we
offer that clicking sound,
tells them you've
done the right thing,
and food reward is on the way.
They aren't born
knowing that, of course.
We retrain that.
We teach them that.
And the consistency
is the key thing
there with all the training.
You can she's holding
there with her front feet.
SPEAKER: Aww, she is so cute.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Very cute, huh?
Well, we'll say
goodbye to Pokey.
We don't stay too much time on
each animal because have a lot
to get through today.
But going up to
the slide here, you
see a gentleman
who looks like he's
brushing the teeth of a camel.
Now, I guarantee you he's not.
I know this because the
upper set of teeth on camels
does not exist.
They only have teeth on
the bottom side, up front.
They have upper and
lower teeth in the back.
But what he's doing,
undoubtedly, there,
is probably offering
some or administering
some sort of
medication to something
that might be going on
underneath that upper lip
of that camel.
But he's the key player in
the next few slides here.
This is Dr. Schroeder.
He was a young veterinarian who
started off at the San Diego
Zoo and worked his way
up to being the director
of our veterinary services.
And really kind of pushed
forward our medical care
for our species.
[INAUDIBLE] pushed forward
for a medical of our species
throughout the Zoological
Society of San Diego.
This here, this
old, old building
is the very first zoo hospital
ever, that we know of anyhow.
In that time of
the 1920s and 30s,
if zoos needed
veterinary assistance,
they would ask for a local
farm vet or a horse vet
or someone else with
somewhat similar experience
to come take care
of those animals.
We built our own veterinary
hospital, hired our own vets,
and allowed us to really
start the very first practices
of better understanding
the care for exotic animals
on a medical level.
This building, by the
way, still exists.
If you go down to Balboa
Park, behind Old Globe, if you
kind of walk in that area,
you can see this building
as currently the offices
for our curators.
So kind of cool--
SPEAKER: Do you still
have [INAUDIBLE]
RICK SCHWARTZ: Oh, yeah.
I was about to say.
So we do have a brand
new hospital at the zoo.
Or not quite brand
new, but newer.
I always like to tell
people that this is actually
a picture of one of our regular
hospitals, human hospitals.
It's not, but it
sure looks like it.
It does give you an idea,
though, the level of care.
This is an inside photo of
our animal care vet hospital
at the Safari Park.
Really state of the art.
And we have a gorilla there
being worked on right now.
Shy of the gorilla
being on the gurney,
it looks like it
could be any hospital.
And that's the level of care
we offer for these animals.
These hospitals are set up
to take care of something
as small as a hummingbird.
So imagine what a tube to tube,
a hummingbird must look like.
Very, very tiny.
All the way up to an elephant
or a rhino and everything
you can think of in between for
birds, mammals and reptiles.
And that's what
always fascinates me
about veterinarians.
Is you go to the doctor, you
can say, oh, it hurts right
behind my left eye.
I think its a sinus thing.
Or its when I do this, it hurts.
Our vets only know what
the keepers have told them
they have seen as far as what
the behavior change might be
or how the affect of
the animal is different.
And they have to
understand what it
could be through their
medicine teaching.
Now, what's super
interesting to me,
though, is, of course, every
animal species is different.
And then you make that leap
from mammal to bird or bird
to reptile.
We have the same veterinarian
doing the same work
on all these different species.
It's truly fascinating,
the work they do
and the quality of
care that they offer.
So we're going to stop there.
I think we have another animal
we're going to bring out.
This is Dr. Schroeder
a bit later.
But we'll get to this
slide in a moment.
We have another animal to
share with you that might be--
I just want to make sure.
Now, there's nobody that
doesn't like snakes, right?
SPEAKER: We heard a gasp.
[LAUGHTER]
RICK SCHWARTZ:
There's one runner.
We always have one in
every group that runs.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
Well, this is Julius Squeezer.
And Julius Squeezer
is a Burmese python.
Now, we get this
question a lot with him.
Is he the biggest snake?
Burmese python are usually
considered in the top five
of snakes, as far as largest.
The reticulated
python and anaconda
usually are the two that we hear
the most about being largest.
But the reticulated
tends to be on record
for being the longest, where
the Anaconda, the heaviest.
It's much thicker but
not quite as long animal.
SPEAKER: Oh, he's looking at me.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Oh, he's yawning.
SPEAKER: Oh it's yawning, OK.
[CHUCKLES]
RICK SCHWARTZ: So
first off, of course,
snakes are very slimy
and gross, right?
No, they're not slimy.
They look slimy.
So you can see how
Julius, right now,
he's got a nice shine to him.
Think of him more as
a well waxed floor,
or a nicely polished car.
And then you get that
wet sort of shine.
Same thing.
They're very dry
and very smooth.
If they were wet and slimy, they
would move more like a slug.
They'd leave a
slime trail along.
But they're very dry
and smooth, so they
can move quickly through
their environment
with minimal friction.
Another myth we hear
a lot about is they
flick their tongue
in and out meaning
they're about to strike.
Not necessarily true either.
They're really have
the opportunity
to sense their
environment by flicking
that tongue in and out.
So when you smell some
nice, freshly brewed coffee
or cupcakes or a
muffin or something
like that, you
really draw that in
because you have sensory
cells up in your nose
that tell your brain
what you're smelling.
You're actually taking
in microscopic particles
of that substance
into your nostrils.
Now, snakes have
nostrils, but it's just
for breathing air in and out.
There's no sensory up there.
The tongue, however, picks
up those same microscopic
particles you and I smell,
brings it into the mouth,
on the roof of the mouth
of the same sensory cells
that tell the brain of the
snake what it's smelling.
Now right now, Julius does not
smell any rats, so Julius is,
like, yeah, kind
of a boring place.
They do have eyes,
obviously, as well.
SPEAKER: He, like,
camouflages with the carpet.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICK SCHWARTZ: I know, right?
When he goes on
the carpet, it's,
like, that could be just gone.
It's perfect camouflage,
though, for the forest floor.
They can be found in sort of the
not quite a full rain forest,
but somewhat forested area.
So the leaf litter and an
organic material on the floor.
That perfect thing, though, it's
kind of like your floor here.
Good camouflage like that.
But like I was saying,
they do have eyes.
But think of it more
of what they can see
is like a black and white
photo that's out of focus.
More contrast and shapes
and shadows and clarity.
They do have the nerves and some
of the bone structure for ears,
but it's encapsulated
in the head.
Most of the sound
they're picking up
is through vibrations
coming into their jaw.
So, really, their main
sense for this species,
especially, is going to
be the flicking in and out
of the tongue.
Some species of snakes
do have better eyesight.
And some do have those heat pits
that can pick up different heat
sensory that way.
So just kind of
depends on the species.
But in general, these are all
kind of basic snake facts.
Of course, now,
being a constrictor,
that means whatever
it catches it has
to be able to swallow it whole.
Well, that's actually
true for all snakes.
They swallow all
their food whole.
General rule of thumb,
they'll eat something
about four times the
size of their head.
So that would be like you
swallowing a watermelon whole.
That's pretty impressive.
Now, they don't actually
unhinge their jaw.
There's an extra bone in there
with some very stretchy rubber
band-like ligaments.
So that'll stretch and open
up nice and wide on the sides.
And up front, there's a
stretching ligament, as well,
which allows it to expand to
the left and to the right.
And then they'll move
their jaw independently
to work like a conveyor belt
to send that food on down.
One last fun fact about snakes.
For the longest
time, studies that
were done on these
big constrictors,
it was always believed, even
with small constrictors as
well, when they grab their
prey and squeeze down,
what they're doing
is suffocating it
because the animal
can't breathe in
as they constrict down and
so, eventually, it passes out.
And that was the thought
process between all
snakes up until, I believe,
it was about six years ago,
there was a study done
by Carnegie Mellon,
and I believe it
was Smithsonian Zoo.
They went with larger snakes
to test the pressure that they
are exerting in a constriction.
They found that the pressure
is so strong and so quick,
that it will actually stop
the blood from flowing
through the body and
seizes the heart.
A much faster and
painless way to go
compared to the thought
process of strangulation
or suffocation.
SPEAKER: Thoughtful
to their prey.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yes.
Yeah, right.
It's very kind of them.
Very kind of them.
All right, we'll bring
Julius around one more time.
SPEAKER: So why's he so sleepy?
When does he sleep?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Well,
the thing about
snakes when they
get to be this big,
there's really not
a lot of reason
to move around or be active.
They're kind of
just pretty chill.
He probably fell asleep on
the ride up here, honestly.
They're not fully
nocturnal, but they
do tend to be a little more
active in the nighttime hours.
SPEAKER: Thank you ladies.
Yes.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Thank
you guys very much.
AUDIENCE: How do the breathe?
RICK SCHWARTZ: They
breathe through their nose.
They have two little holes up
front, and it comes right in.
Just like you and I
breathe, essentially.
You know, inside
their body, they
have all the same
things you and I have.
I could talk for the entire
half hour about cool snake
adaptations.
But, essentially, the tail
is only a very small portion
at the end.
And so from the neck
to that tail point
they have everything
you have in your body
just elongated in a tubular
system, essentially.
One long, giant lung
and one smaller lung.
They're fascinating.
It really is.
But speaking of
fascinating, our slide
right here, Dr. Schroeder,
after he was been with the zoo
for so long as the head doctor
for veterinary medicine,
he moved on to New York to
lead one of the zoo's out there
and then was asked to come
back and join us when we had
one of our directors retire.
And he then had this
idea that, you know,
we can't-- this
is probably 1960s.
OK.
To give you an idea.
1960s, he had this
thought, we can't keep
taking animals from the wild.
It's not sustainable.
How many people in the
1960s were really thinking
about animal welfare
and conservation?
Not a whole lot.
So he thought we should do
this breeding program where
we breed these animals
here in the United States
and supply zoos
with those animals.
And he thought it'd be cool if
we did this in the San Pasqual
Valley.
You know where I'm
going with this, right?
So he's tried to pitch that
to the city, to the board.
Everyone's, like, you're crazy.
There's no way.
So the thing about
conservation and animal care,
it's a major financial loss.
There's very little chance
to earn a lot of money
and make money.
So when you try to pitch
it to business people,
they usually don't want
to be a part of it.
Well, he was very visionary.
So this picture
is actually of him
out there in San Pasqual Valley
once he got the OK to do this.
He's hammering in
the stakes for where
they put the original tram.
So the original
monorail tram that
went out there, the
director of our organization
plotted that trail.
So pretty impressive.
The stories about this guy
and everything he's done
is pretty remarkable.
This shot here, is once
we had giraffe out there
in the open areas of what
we now call the Safari Park.
At the time it was, I believe,
San Diego Zoo's San Pasqual
Wild Animal Park.
And over the years,
since it opened in 1972,
it's gone through many
different name changes.
But currently, we're at
San Diego Zoo Safari Park.
It looks a lot different
now, of course.
But this was our original
giraffe herd out there.
And, again, it was very
visionary thought process
that we need to create a very
large, open space to breed
these animals.
Dr. Schroeder knew.
He knew people
would be interested,
and they'd want to see it.
Everyone else wasn't too sure.
They initially weren't going
to open it to the public.
But after the first
year of animals
being out there and traffic
being backed up on highway 78,
he was, like, see.
So they opened it
up to the public in,
I believe, it was May of 1972.
And it's been going
strong ever since.
So here's a great shot of
one of our white rhinos.
We're well known for
breeding our white rhinos.
And then the monorail,
the original monorail,
in the background there.
I always get asked, why did
they take away the monorail?
The company that
built the monorail
was a European company that
went under years and years ago.
Long before we took
the monorail away,
our awesome mechanics
were actually
machining parts for this
thing to keep it going.
And eventually, it got to
the point where they just
couldn't-- without
completely rebuilding it--
couldn't keep it going.
So we've now gone to a
biofuel system that's
not on a monorail, so multiple
ones can be going, if need be.
Then, of course, this takes
us to our more current day
as well.
We have a lot of different
safari experiences
at the Safari Park.
Our goal is not to
just have world class
care for our animals and
work with conservation
around the world, which we do,
but also to offer our guests
these unique experiences.
One thing we've
definitely found,
and I think you guys might
have already experienced
a little with the two
animals we've had out here,
would you have that
opportunity to be
up close with an
animal, the opportunity
to look at its adaptations and
its attributes, have it, maybe,
look you in the eye.
It changes you.
And we hope that it
changes you for the better.
To get you to maybe
think about what
you can do for conservation,
whether it's on a local level
or on a grander level and
then some of the projects
that we do.
So we're going to go to
this next animal coming up,
and we're going talk about how
our goal is to end extinction.
And we have some more slides
to support our conservation
work as well.
But this particular owl coming
out right now, this is Dudley.
He's not a baby.
He's a full grown owl.
Anybody know the species?
They live right here
in Southern California.
AUDIENCE: Screech owl.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Close.
Screech owls are
very close in size.
AUDIENCE: Burrowing owl.
RICK SCHWARTZ: There you go.
I heard the guess.
Hi, buddy.
How are you?
Dudley's a burrowing owl.
SPEAKER: He's a curious fellow.
RICK SCHWARTZ: He is.
Burrowing owls have
really had a rough go
here in Southern California and
their other native habitats.
Because as we grow
our urban areas,
we grow right into
their natural area
of where they want to live.
And a lot of the animals that
burrow into the ground that
create their burrows.
They don't burrow themselves.
They kind of take over
other abandoned burrows.
We have eradicated a lot
of those species, too.
So it makes it very challenging
for this species to thrive.
And they're really
important with the ecosystem
because they eat a lot of
different bugs, small rodents,
and small reptiles.
And so they help really
establish a balanced ecosystem.
So when we lose this apex
predator that the owl is,
we start to see an
influx of things,
and we have other
problems that occur.
When we take away the
burrowing animals,
and they can't live
there any longer,
too, it changes the
soil, so it changes how
the plants can grow as well.
And so that impacts
our watershed.
So all of a sudden, you see how
tied in all these things are--
SPEAKER: Everything's connected.
RICK SCHWARTZ: --to
one little species.
Yeah, everything is connected.
SPEAKER: So how many
of them are left?
RICK SCHWARTZ: There's
pockets of several thousand
throughout Southern California.
And the really
cool thing is we've
been able to partner with a
lot of government agencies
recently.
And there's multiple
agencies working together now
to put safe haven.
And we're reintroducing
a lot of the species that
make their burrows.
So ground squirrels here,
and pocket mice as well.
We're working on projects
here in San Diego County that
are reestablishing that, so they
can also re-establish, then,
their territories as well.
We've had ongoing
studies at the Safari
Park and the Zoo about
what's best housing.
Because there are
fewer burrows for them,
we're creating man-made
burrows to help
get them established as well.
So a lot of the work we
do in the zoo environment
is very important
for, then, what
we can do in the
conservation in the field
and work with that there.
And Dudley's a
great example, too,
how even as a small
animal, he still
has all those great
things a predator has.
Nice sharp talons.
A very sharp beak as well.
They will live in a burrow.
Mom will lay probably
anywhere from six to 12 eggs.
They'll stay there in the
burrow for a little bit
and then fledge around
four months or so.
Again, it was really cool, too.
They have seen them
stashing some of their food.
We don't see that
in owls very often.
Usually an owl eats what
it catches right away.
Burrowing owls,
they can be active
at daytime or nighttime hours.
And if they catch more food than
they're going eat in a moment,
they'll stash it
in their burrow.
So it's actually kind
of interesting to see
that behavior in an owl.
SPEAKER: So how does
the operation all work?
Because you have
the San Diego Zoo.
You have the Safari Park.
It's all connected.
RICK SCHWARTZ:
Yeah.
So early on, of course, San
Diego Zoo started in 1916.
The early 1970s, the
Safari Park is all
under San Diego Zoo Global.
So I talked earlier
about the Zoological
Society of San
Diego, the nonprofit
that Dr. Harry started.
We're now called
San Diego Zoo Global
because we are a global entity.
We have over, I believe,
130 conservation projects
around the world and roughly
about 70 different countries
along with the Zoo, the
Safari Park, and our Institute
for Conservation Research.
So that kind of brings
us into our next slide.
San Diego Zoo Global, as
a nonprofit organization,
oversees all three of those
entities along with all
those conservations.
And it's great because our
guests can come and enjoy
the parks, but they
can also join us
in our conservation efforts.
And to kind of have some
fun visuals for that.
The Americas, here,
kind of show some
of the projects we're
working on currently
or have worked on in the past.
Kind of a brief overview of
all the different species
from Andean condor to California
condor, thick-billed parrot.
You'll even see
there's some cactus
and other plants in there.
Certainly, near the
very bottom, you'll
see the alala, which is the
Hawaiian crow, a species
fundamentally extinct in the
wild for the last three years
or more, I believe.
We have just reintroduced
a group of them
back into the wild
there in Hawaii.
And it's so important, too,
because they are a seed
disperser for native species
of Hawaiian plants that cannot
grow properly in the habitat
without the crow supporting
the seed dispersal.
So, again, you see how it's
all tied together that way.
This slide here
shows what we refer
to as old-world Africa
and Asia and Europe,
and a lot of the
projects we're working
on around the world, including
some of our work in Australia
as well.
I had the pleasure of going
off the coast of Queensland
to do some of our koala
research there as well.
So it's really just wonderful.
And the great thing
about all of these
projects that we
talk about, and we're
kind of running through
quickly because I
know we're running tight on
time, all of these projects,
we send our keeper
staff out there,
we send our
veterinarians out there.
The people who have
had hands-on experience
caring for these
animals in close
proximity can be so
useful in conservation
when you're dealing with
sick or injured animals
out there in the wild and
be able to set up programs.
One of the more active
programs, we're currently
working on African penguins.
And our Africa Rocks just
opened last summer at the Zoo.
SPEAKER: I was going to
ask you, what's next?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Well, that's
just launched this last summer,
was Africa Rocks.
And with that, we have
our African penguins.
And we have keepers that are
going to Africa to work there
at the conservation site at
the southern tip of Africa.
It's called SANCCOB.
It's, I believe,
something about--
I don't remember the acronym
as far off the top of my head--
but essentially
about seabirds, they
take care of all these
sick and injured birds.
And we're talking
hundreds of penguins.
And they're a critically
endangered species.
And so to have a
seasoned staff to be
able to go in and take care and
help and train other people,
and then come back to the zoo
and take the knowledge they
have and share that
with our audience
that we have at the zoo,
it's absolutely wonderful.
SPEAKER: How do
you transport them?
RICK SCHWARTZ: The
people or the animals?
SPEAKER: The animals.
RICK SCHWARTZ: [LAUGHS]
It depends on the species.
It depends on where they
need to be transported to.
Essentially, though, we have--
So, again, depending upon
the distance and the type
of transportation
for the species,
we basically come up with
the most appropriate and safe
travel crate for
them that allows
them to move properly,
eat properly, drink
properly, but still be
safe while traveling, too.
So, of course, you can't
put a seat belt on them.
So with that, I think--
Oh.
This slide here
kind of gives you
a quick overview that, you
know, that whether you think
they're really cute like the
baby elephant or the cheetah,
or not so cute as a condor,
they're all important.
We do take care of all of them.
And this slide's
particularly important
because with the
cheetahs, there's
a bottleneck in the genetics.
And we were told that you could
never successfully save them.
The breeding program
we have is, I believe,
we're over 60-some babies
now, and the program
is going exceptionally well.
With the California
condor, when the last few
were brought in in
the 80s, we were
told that it would never work.
They were just
going to go extinct.
There were only 22 left.
There's now over 480 in
the population, about half
of that flying back in the
wild where they belong.
And the same with African
elephants, the challenges
we face there.
We're being told that
it may not be something
you can do to save them.
But, realistically,
we believe we can.
So we're working on that.
So with that, I think
we have one more animal.
It's going to come out for you.
The videos, too, to play,
but I heard the clickers.
I know she's out.
We'll do the videos
after the serval.
AUDIENCE: When you said
the bottleneck in genetics,
what does that mean?
RICK SCHWARTZ:
Essentially, some people
believe that there are too
few left in the population
to offer up enough
diversity to allow
them to thrive in the future.
So sometimes what you see in
a bottleneck of population
is inbreeding concerns.
And then you have health
deterioration, other things
that get passed on.
But we believe with using
the science that we have,
we can best mitigate
those challenges
and offer up as much diversity
as possible with what there is.
So this is not a
cheetah, though.
For those of you who
went, aww, a cheetah.
It's not a cheetah.
Sorry.
We refer to this sometimes
as the poor man's cheetah,
but there's nothing
poor about this animal.
So she actually ties
into the video we're
going to watch here shortly.
It's the giraffe cat,
or the giraffe of cats.
It's an African serval.
They have the longest
legs of any cat
in relation to the body
size and also the largest
ears in relation to body size.
Those giant ears-- now, this is
a full grown cat, by the way.
She's not going
to get any bigger.
We always get asked, when is
she going to grow into our ears?
They use their
ears for listening
for birds flying towards them.
They can actually leap 10
feet or more into the air
and grab that bird out of
mid-flight to feed on it.
They will also listen
for rodents underground
and time their pounce just
right to grab that rodent as it
comes up from underground.
You might notice her short tail.
Sometimes we get asked,
what happened to her tail?
Well, nothing
happened to her tail.
As Bella does come by, just
don't reach out for her.
And those of you standing
in the aisle, just kind of
stand off to the
side a little bit.
Give her some room.
Definitely can appreciate her,
just don't reach out for her.
You'll see Ashley's
offering food from the hand.
If you reach your hand out,
and there's no food in it,
your hand becomes a food, and
that's a lot of paperwork.
I don't want to
do that paperwork.
So just admire her from there.
There you go.
You see the white spots
on the back of the ears?
Oh, I was talking
about the tail.
The tail is short because
they don't need a long tail.
A tail is used for balance.
Leopards and jaguars, cheetahs,
all have these nice long tails.
They need it for balance whether
they're climbing or chasing
their prey.
Snow leopards do a lot of rock
climbing, nice long bushy tail.
Animals that don't do a
lot of climbing or chasing
don't need that tail, so it
would just get in the way.
They're a leaper and a pouncer.
They're going to stay
in a static position
and leap straight up
to grab their prey.
Or they're going to stay
in that static position
and leap a distance
to grab their prey.
A long tail would
just get in the way.
It's not needed.
The white spots you see
on the back of the ears
are sometimes referred to
me as "follow me" spots.
It is believed by
some scientists
that the kittens can
follow mom easier
with the contrast of
the black and white
on the back of
the ear like that.
Another theory out there
is that if Bella had just
captured some prey, and
she's got her head down,
and she's eating
it, those ears--
she's not going to
get you-- those ears,
whether she was
sitting like this,
and I was a predator
sneaking up to get her.
Or she was looking down,
and I was coming at her
to get her to steal her
food, that's a big deal.
Servals are great hunters.
They are one of the few cats
that have a high success
rate of kill per attempt.
So a lot of animals are going
to want to steal their food.
If at a distance, I thought
those were eyes looking
at me with that black
and white contrast,
I would either stop
my forward movement,
or I'd try and circle around.
Either way, buying her
more time or possibly
giving away my actual location
because those aren't really her
eyes looking at me.
Her eyes are forward that way.
SPEAKER: And what is she eating?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Meat.
We have a carnivore meat diet
for all of our carnivores.
It is a beef-base
sort of ground.
It looks kind of
like a hamburger,
but you wouldn't want
it in your burger.
It's got a lot more stuff in it.
SPEAKER: Is she a
tough one to train?
She looks pretty lovey.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Not really, Yeah.
We find servals and most
of our cat species--
as much as people say
you can't train a cat.
You can.
Consistency is key for
any training, of course.
But definitely for our servals,
they are a willing animal.
They enjoy coming out
and doing the work.
And they do understand the
concept of a food reward
situation.
And you can see, she's nice and
calm over there, hanging out,
having a good time.
And they're more than
happy to do stuff for us
and show off their
different attributes.
Can Bella stay out
for a bit while we
run through these
videos real quick?
I don't know.
Is there a button I need
to push for the videos?
SPEAKER: Yeah, just click it.
RICK SCHWARTZ: All right.
SPEAKER: There you go.
This is a short video of
our most recently opened
giraffe orphanage in Kenya.
So the giraffe calf in
the giraffe orphanage.
Unfortunately,
giraffe are in peril.
We have a lot of focus
and a lot of information
out there about elephants due
to tusk poaching and rhinos
due to horn poaching.
Unfortunately, the
giraffe is also
dealing with
degradation of habitat
and also being used as
target practice by poachers.
So all of a sudden, we
realize through research,
they have dropped their
population immensely.
And when the adults are,
unfortunately, poached as well,
we have babies that
are in need of care.
The gentleman that's
doing the care here,
he is in charge of the orphanage
along with the other gentlemen
you saw, that was one of
our researchers helping out.
We're funding this orphanage and
sending our vet staff out there
and offering up different milk
for the giraffe to grow on.
But what's most, for
me, the gentleman
you see in the video right now.
You ask the folks
that work there,
you ask them why do you do this?
Why is it important to you?
And because they grew up with
these animals in their life,
they heard goats or cows
in the same environment.
The ones that do the
herding are the children.
So they grow up with the
zebra and the giraffe.
And they tell me every time.
When I've ever asked,
whether it's for the zebra
or for the giraffe, they say
because they're my friends.
This is who I grew up with.
And to think that they could
go extinct and no longer be
with us, I can't
let that happen.
So they literally
dedicate their life
to doing the work that you just
saw there at the orphanage.
And it's tough work.
That's the middle of Kenya.
There's not a whole lot of
facilities around there.
I think there's--
SPEAKER: Wow, that's amazing.
We have one more video, right?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah.
One more video about
giraffe conservation.
Again, one of our
most recent projects.
We've really been
doing a lot of work.
And we're working with
different organizations.
It's not just us.
It must be said.
Others zoos work together.
Other organizations like
the Kenya Wildlife Services
as well.
And we do giraffe tracking
where part of the program
where teams will go out,
what you see right there.
They knock the giraffe down
with a chemical knock down,
so it's a dart.
And they are fastening
something no bigger
than a small cell phone to
one of the ossicones, which
is like a horn.
In the next shot
coming up, you'll
see it looks like a
little pager on it,
strapped to the top
of the one there.
That is a satellite tracker
that'll last three years.
It allows us to track them
from the comfort of San Diego
or wherever.
The patterns of that giraffe
tell what kind of habitat
they need, where they're
going, how they interface
with other giraffe as well.
And it really gives us
a better understanding
of giraffes in the wild
because you can't always
be there where the are.
So those are the
two short videos
I have on our
giraffe conservation.
I know you had one more
video to share, too.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I have--
RICK SCHWARTZ: With our tie in--
SPEAKER: --one video.
RICK SCHWARTZ: --of our
organization and yours.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So hopefully, I mean, hopefully,
you all know your own Google
history.
But we're definitely
tied to the San Diego Zoo
as well, aside from just this
office celebrating you guys.
But I'm going to show
you a quick video.
JAWED KARIM: All right.
So here we are in
front of the elephants.
The whole thing about these
guys is that they have really,
really, really long trunks.
And that's cool.
And that's pretty much
all there is to say.
SPEAKER: So I don't know if
you all remember this video.
It was shot in 2005.
This is the first
official YouTube video
ever uploaded by the co-founder
of the website back then.
And he's at the San Diego Zoo.
So if you also know
there's a team at Google
called "the zoo," which
is a creative team.
But we're definitely connected
to this San Diego Zoo,
and I thought it was something
to bring it back to us
and our culture
and the connection.
RICK SCHWARTZ: And one
thing we definitely
say about that, it's fun to have
that connection with you guys
because every time YouTube
celebrates its anniversary,
our name comes up as well.
San Diego Zoo has been
around long enough
and is known well
enough that we're
in a lot of cultural things.
In different movies it
comes up, or TV shows,
it comes up as well.
So that's always fun for us.
But one of the key takeaways.
If there's nothing else
that this particular video
shows is the San
Diego Zoo couldn't
be what it is or do what
it does without the support
we have in San Diego proper.
Our membership is one of the
largest memberships anywhere
in zoos.
Our community support
has always been
way above the par for any
organization on any given
year for a nonprofit that runs
a Zoological Society as well.
So we're really proud to be
part of the San Diego community.
We're proud of the support
we always get from San Diego
as well, whether it's for a
YouTube video, our local parks,
or even some of the conservation
we talked about today
around the world.
SPEAKER: Well, I'm
going to open it up
to a couple questions in the
audience if they have any.
I'll just repeat your question,
so that the video can catch it
for you guys.
But do we have any
questions in the audience?
RICK SCHWARTZ: I see
a couple of hands.
Which one?
Who has their hand--
OK.
Go, Hadi.
AUDIENCE: Did the
satellite tracker
they could have for
three years, does it
stay without any need
to recharge that?
SPEAKER: So is there a need to
recharge the satellite trackers
on the giraffe?
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah, usually
what will happen is--
so short answer, yes.
But what happens is the
straps will wear out
from the weather in those three
years, and it will fall off.
And we can usually retrieve
it before the battery dies.
And so that allows us to
reuse the system that way.
And usually two to three
years of information
from a single giraffe is
sufficient to gather what
we need from that individual.
And we can then
utilize that tool
to gather it from
another individual.
SPEAKER: Up here?
AUDIENCE: With the
issue of poaching,
right, across the
globe, what type
of extra security measures--
I'm assuming that if you
go into certain regions
there's additional
threats, right?
So not only the livelihood
of the animals, but also
the humans that are there to
assist-- what type of effort
goes into planning and
protecting both the animals
and humans?
SPEAKER: So the question
was around the precautions.
There's all these
dangers around poaching.
What is the zoo doing from
San Diego local and then
also across all the conservation
areas you guys have?
RICK SCHWARTZ: First to
address what the threats are
and how it's being addressed.
For lack of a better term,
there are rangers deployed
that are trained.
And most recently, they have
also given these rangers
an extra tool of guard dogs,
both from the shepherd type
attitude dog that has
to grab and obtain
a person of interest, but also
hound dogs to find the people,
to track them.
I was fortunate enough,
when I was in Kenya
a couple of years ago, I got
to play the part of a poacher.
And I went and hid off
in this washout area.
And we were able to
get that on film.
We made a nice little video--
it's on YouTube, by the way--
that shows how they use the
dogs to track poachers and find
people.
It was a really great
experience to be a part of that
and see that.
So if you look at
places, there's
organization we work
with called Lewa.
It's in Kenya.
They have had no
poaching, I think,
for the last two or three years
because of the large population
of rangers they have hired
along with these dogs.
The Rangers have also found,
and Lewa works very, very hard
to get the community outlying
of the secure park area
to be a part of the
larger community.
Because that way,
when some stranger
comes and starts
asking questions
about rhinos or
elephants, they're
going to tell their
friends or the rangers.
The rangers can go check
out what's going on,
and it's been very effective.
Now, that model works
really well there.
There are other
places where they
don't have the funding,
necessarily, to do that,
or they haven't
gotten there yet.
And others, where
sometimes, the poachers
are just more
aggressive than they're
going to expect, coming in
with military-style vehicles,
essentially, in the
middle of the night.
So what we're doing as an
organization-- we fund a lot.
We partner up with these groups,
whether it's Lewa or Northgate,
or all these other
organizations we work with,
and we helped raise money.
We're really good at raising
money because of the support we
have in San Diego.
And we funnel that money.
As a nonprofit, it's very easy
for us to do those fundraisers,
take some of our ticket
sales, whatever it may be,
and funnel that
money over to areas
that need that help so they
can fund those rangers,
fund that equipment, fund the
dog care, and things like that.
And it works out pretty well.
SPEAKER: That's great to
partner with you guys.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Here, a
question in the front.
AUDIENCE: For predator type
animals, in Safari Park,
do you have environments for
them to actually hunt, or are
they eating everything
that's provided by staff.
RICK SCHWARTZ: You want
to ask the question again?
Or should I--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICK SCHWARTZ: OK.
So what he's
asking, essentially,
is do the predators we
have have the opportunity
to express the natural
behavior of hunting
in the environments we have
at the Safari Park or Zoo?
Short answer is not
exactly but kind of.
So the food they consume.
We do not feed--
SPEAKER: Pokey's
out again, guys.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yes.
Pokey's out for Q&A, as well.
We thought it would be fun to
have the animals out doing Q&A
to keep you guys entertained.
But the predators we have,
the food they consume
is already deceased.
Now, some will have a rabbit or
a rat such as our large snake
you saw out earlier.
Our large carnivores
get carnivore meat diet,
sort of a mixture of things.
Plus they have femur
bones to chew on,
so they can express
with chewing behaviors.
But we recognize,
sometimes, that if you
you're to feed
out a live animal,
there's a lot of
responsibilities
that you would have
to that live animal
as well until the predator
makes the proper kill.
So with that, we choose not to
go that route with the largers.
I guess sort of a side
note to that, though.
Just the other day, we gave
large mouth bass, live ones,
to our polar bears,
so they could
express the hunting of fish.
So, you know, checks
and balances on that.
But as far as letting a
deer go in the lion exhibit,
no, we don't do that.
[CHUCKLES]
SPEAKER: Last question.
AUDIENCE: Could you share
one of the local conservation
[INAUDIBLE]?
In addition to the burrowing
owl, there's other birds--
RICK SCHWARTZ: Oh certainly.
The list is too
long to answer now.
I would just say, first off,
go to endextinction.org.
That's kind of our landing site
for all of our conservation
including local stuff.
But yes, cactus wren,
pocket mouse, burrowing owl.
Well, there is burrowing owl.
You know, all of those.
And then a lot of
plant species as well.
People don't realize
our Institute
for Conservation Research has
a whole horticulture wing where
they harvest seeds
from endangered species
we have right here in San Diego.
Fun fact for you.
From coast to mountain,
San Diego County
is the most species-diverse
county in the United States.
Think about that for a second.
That's pretty impressive.
You live right there in
the most diverse county,
but we also have
a lot of growth.
So we see a lot
of these habitats
being changed and
having some challenges.
A lot of plant species
having problems too.
So our teams will go
out and harvest seeds
and also grow and
germinate those plants.
And then we have areas where,
similar to our animals,
we set up for these conservation
sites to grow those plants
and give them that stronghold
to bring that environment back
to where it should be.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much,
Rick, for joining us.
For bringing all your
furry and non-furry animals
and your staff to
take care of them.
Congratulations for all of
your work and conservation
and what's to come.
I'm sure there's more.
And hopefully, you all
visit the San Diego Zoo,
if you haven't already.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah.
And for those of you
watching, too, San Diego Zoo
has a great YouTube channel.
So you can hop over
there and check that out.
SPEAKER: Oh, I love that.
I didn't even tell you
to say all these things.
RICK SCHWARTZ: No.
We're very active
on social media.
You can find San Diego Zoo
or the SDZ Safari Park.
That's the handle
for two facilities.
And if you have any
questions for me,
you can always hit me up
as Zookeeper Rick, too.
I love interacting on
social media for everybody,
answering questions
about wildlife,
and sharing fun facts, too.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
all for coming out.
RICK SCHWARTZ: Yeah.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
SPEAKER: See you next time.
[APPLAUSE]